Madam President
honorable members have listened very
careful late to this debate and I do
understand your concerns as you know
this is an old dispute between the EU
and the u.s. Airbus Boeing it's been
going on for 15 years there's a huge
room of papers on only this case in
Geneva and it has certainly paid the
wages of many lawyers WTO has found that
both the EU and the US have been guilty
in giving unauthorized subsidies to
Boeing and Airbus this gives the formal
right to us now and to us a little bit
later next year to impose tariffs we are
preparing and we have made that very
clear to the u.s. that we are preparing
such a list as well to have if it would
be needed however as many of you have
said we already have too many tariffs in
this world and that is why we have been
pushing for a negotiated solution we
have provided quite detailed elements of
what we could do on both sides for
existing past and future subsidies in
this area because some subsidies have
been allowed some have been condemned
some have disappeared some are in the
process of being disappeared but it has
of course to be a balanced process where
both boeing and airbus dismantle z' and
this is a process that we have asked the
the americans to engage in i have raised
it personally we are ambassador light i
sir several times I know that member
states some of you and others had passed
the same message so we've been perfectly
United there we have also proposed that
apart from disciplining ourselves that
we should set global standards because
the big problem in the future will be
other big economies who are already
today massively subsidizing their civil
aircraft and if we could put some global
standards here it would be useful
unfortunately us have not at this point
been willing to engage we will keep on
pushing of course but so far that has
not been possible and
we are here today stuck with tariffs and
of course this probe disproportionately
and that is totally deliberate from the
US side affecting the agricultural
sector I am aware and so is Phil Hogan
and the whole Commission of the social
and economic difficulties in sectors in
regions and whole countries that this is
causing this is serious and it is urgent
and that is why since quite some time we
are assessing the situation as I said in
my introduction there are several tools
at our disposal some have already been
announced a flexibility and promotion
there might be others as well but we
need to be totally clear on what we do
what are the consequences of the US
tariffs and what are consequences of
other market distortions or other
problems because we need to be able to
design target that measures effective
measures and they need to be WTO
compliant and that is what is is doing
right now I would like to reject firmly
the notion that the trade policy has
been a disadvantage for the agriculture
market on the contrary and there are
several independent reports proving that
the latest trade deals that we have done
with Japan with Canada now with
Singapore entering into force and also
with future agreements with Vietnam
Mercosur Mexico are and will be hugely
beneficial to the European agriculture
sector we're opening up new markets for
products that are highly in demand from
all over the world and this is of course
also very important for Agriculture's
having said that I do not in any way
want to dismiss the problems that
farmers and the agriculture and the wine
sector are facing here today and this is
why our services in this commission and
the coming Commission will finalize the
study and the analysis and come back to
you and Member States we discussed it at
the trade council meeting last week with
member states as well very soon on
further action in this field thank you
very much madam president for this
debate feeling for commerce aaron